Here's a different system of equations. The coefficients to the x are different,
and the coefficients for y are different. Hm, so what could we do? Well, we can
actually use the properties of equality to change one of these equations or both
of them. Here's what I mean. I can think about changing the second equation by
multiplying it by a positive 2. When I do that I distribute this 2 to each of
the terms, 2 times 3x is 6x, 2 times negative 4y is negative 8y and 2 times 10
is 20. Make sure that you distribute this number to each term. So I know this
green equation is the same as this equation, it's been multiplied by 2. So I've
rewritten my system of equation here, and notice the y variables have the same
coefficient and opposite signs. This is great. Now using our elimination method,
I want you to solve this system. You can put your answer here.